okay good morning everyone and as I said
before welcome to this meeting of
development control committee a just
first of all I'd like to run through
some of the domestic arrangements please
can you please ensure that your
microphones are muted when you're not
speaking and if you fail to do that
you'll find that I'll probably or
someone may mute you please don't take
offense it's just to prevent any
background noise that may come through
it's obviously important that we don't
interrupt each other if we use the text
box if you wish to speak and just put
your so you'd like to speak and then
I'll bring you in at the relevant time
please members also reminded not to use
messaging chat functions during the
meeting and this is to a quarter report
a pecuniary non-pecuniary interest and
if you wish to make a proposal regarding
the applications before us if you notify
me that that's what you wish to do
members are reminded they should not
have other lines of communication open i
Skype chats and if you're contacted by a
third-party application that's right
third party during an application please
let us know during this meeting if
you're attending the meeting to speak
and you're interrupting the meeting you
will be asked to leave the meeting
additionally you'll be most to speak
when it is your turn we keep to the same
rules as before three minutes for anyone
wishing to speak and it will become
clear that there is in front of us on
the screen there will be a timer so that
you'll be able to see how much time has
gone and how much time is remaining
I'd like to mind everyone present this
meeting will be broadcast live and is
being broadcast live on the internet and
will be capable of repeated viewings the
whole of the meeting will also be
recorded except where they're
confidential exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you'll be
deemed by the council to have consented
to being recorded by entrance meeting as
a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings but we're
casting and/or training purposes the
council members of the public and press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting when the public and press
are not lawfully excluded I just like to
run through the people that are present
on the call with us today here we can
call on at any time to assist we have in
Dupre's who's our legal adviser welcome
in we help Claire Philpott our
governance officer welcome Claire Tom
Pittman ji is in the call he's our area
planning manager welcomed Ron and Jack
Wilkinson as the case officer we'll be
presenting today and now we have the
applicant we have maybe with the members
of the public present on my list we have
the Parrish Clark
we have Caroline Walton and Chris Smith
who their time for the opportunity to
speak during the application before us
okay so and James Caston is with us he's
the ward member who has the opportunity
to speak on the application but not the
baby so I'm going to move us on to the
agenda and the first item on the agenda
is apologies for absence and
substitutions can I ask the governance
officer to just roll call the members
present please Thank You chair members
when I call your name if you could just
indicate your presence for me please
councillor Rachel eben present
councillor John field councillor live in
the air having him present
councillor Matthew Hicks counts the fair
amounts all council John Patterson
councillor Richard Mayer councillor Dave
Miller present and councillor James
Caston
sorry present hit their own button sorry
thank you item number two to receive any
tech graces of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
members do you have any decorations to
declare can you try it one more time
there is a problem with your line John
and what I think you'll need to do is
log out and login again you're coming in
over with a very high-pitched voice it's
there's something wrong on the line
[Music]
sorry John we can't hear any of that at
all if you want to type anything but I
think you log out and John has left good
we'll just give him one minute just to
log on again mr. chairman if I might
just um say that um this exact same
thing happened in a young seminar I'm
just the other day and it was because
the member was using a headset and as
soon as he unplugged their headset he
was back to normal again
okay I'm using a headset I only ever
used a headset so okay we'll try that
let's see what went wrong it could be
I'm saying yeah
so I am i back on your back and we can
hear you loud and clear so that's good
job the sixth time to log on I just
needed to declare two issues I neither
which opportunity really the first issue
is that on counter counselor for this
area
we should not that's the Brantford
application the second thing I have an
involvement as a trustee with an
application which is mentioned a few
occasions at the Brantford end of Sprott
and the one that's mentioned the
Jason to the first award Thank You
chairman cash the field yes I heard all
that and I'm happy to advise the field
has properly declared those matters and
well the first one is of not usually is
usually declared for the sake of
performance but to move on agenda item
number three decorations of lobbying now
I suspect all members have received an
email from the applicant any other
lobbying I think anyone else to register
any further lobbying on this application
John field again yes that I have been
lobbied over some months you must
remember at one time I was board member
for this area yeah thank you
anyone else yeah week my I received an
email from Caroline Walton yeah I think
we all have received that email so I
think for the record we've all received
lobbying on on the applications before
us okay thank you very much members
agenda item number 4 is decorations of
personal site visits does anyone have a
personal site visit to declare no okay
thank you very much agenda item number
five is confirmation the minutes of the
meeting here on 13th of May 2020 he's
our league and our papers on page seven
to ten and if I just run through each
page if you have anything please just do
feel free to come in page seven page
eight and page nine is everyone happy
that I signed those
record of the meeting if you're not
happy please speak otherwise I'll take
this as given
thank you I'll sign those after us okay
agenda item number six to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the councilors petition scheme
can I ask please the government's office
to report on this do we have in it
there's none receive chair thank you
very much okay attender and I will now
ask the area planning manager to report
on the applications that were to be
heard by the committee but have
subsequently been withdrawn
are there any John
don't paint Minji sorry counsel that
something went wrong here
could you just repeat the question for
me under the order of business it says
that I will now ask the Arab planning
manager to report on any applications to
be heard by the committee that have been
subsequently withdrawn now that may be I
know that happened in the last meeting
but is there anything to this meeting
please no I don't I'm not aware of
anything chairman for over 40 at this
time okay very much okay so we'll now go
straight to agenda item 7 schedule of
planning applications are now asked the
case officer Jack Wilkinson to introduce
the application to committee over thank
you sure I'm just going to bring up the
PowerPoint hoping you'll be able to see
just why that's happening just to be
clear this is DC 1901 401 and DC 1901
six four nine land to the south of
Fitzgerald road in brothel
I think with this lost Jack all together
I'll be back on here we go
sorry chair what happened there perfect
so if a pond gets to the widescreen
Thank You chair good morning members
members of the public
I'm Jack Wilkinson I'm a principal
planner on the diem service for bayberry
mid Suffolk the first only item for
today is lying to the sample Fitzgerald
Road in Brantford you will know the two
application references as a twin tracker
application so in terms of what we're
here to determine today the planning
application is an outline application ie
the principle of development and access
this is summarizing the proposal as
outlined an application with some
matters reserved for a residential
development of up to 115 dwellings and
access including open space and
landscaping just to give you an idea of
where we are as depicted by the red
marker where amongst the Ipswich bridge
towards the southern extent of Brantford
a 14 to the east brought in to the south
played in a little Blake on to the north
as mentioned we are situated to the
south of Brantford I will zoom in on
better quality image in a minute
the site is outline outline as hatched I
think what is also worth mention is the
district boundary as depicted by the
black line which hope you can see with
my cursor so we have parish of Brantford
here and neighboring Broughton in a
district of Weber towards the south as
per the existing local plan Brantford is
defined as a key service center and the
extent of the blue line shows the
settlement boundary and the application
site is outlined in red just to give you
that distinction in terms of the
emerging joint local plan and that
reminds of limited weight but it is
worth mentioning with regards to
emerging policy la 0:06 which does
identify the site for residential
housing this is outlined on page 26 of
your papers you've seen that the red
line outline is largely covered within
the Sarah
in terms of the defined sight outline I
what we would rely upon in terms of the
plan and an accurate extent with detail
is as shown the applicant also have ins
the defined blue line area the land is
divided by grade two and grade three
agricultural land much of the district
is set in this form and that's
worthwhile mentioning in terms of the
landscape quality in terms of how the
site looks from the air and indeed from
the ground which I'll take you onto in a
moment with some site photos the built
form as you can see is put on e to the
north
I mean to backdrop of the village which
is where this I the painted towards the
west we have to be eleven one three it's
an arterial road the links brantford to
broaden and hips which edge along with a
link north towards do fourteen it's an
arterial route the Fitzgerald Road along
the north as well and with bus stops
leading into the center of the key
service center of Brantford
just to remind members this is an
indicative master plan we are looking at
online application for up to 115 units
with access so the principle of
development with access will be for
debate I think it's prudent to show this
image to show how the site could be
developed and sent me taking account of
the landscaping the open space and
playing areas the flood attenuation
connectivity among society and indeed to
the wider area the public right-of-way
which runs through the center and the
access points wife this drawing may seem
a little chaotic I'm including to
include it because it does show how the
site would sit within the context of the
locality given the contour the land
rises out of out of shot West but it is
predominantly flat as you can see from
the contour lines so in terms of the
landscaping this is a man the officers
have considered in depth and you'll note
that whilst this is indicative we have
sought to capture this through condition
there's no objection from the landscape
consultant subject to a 10-year buffer
advance planting towards the frontage
the site was predominantly open and much
of the site as existing is arable field
your local flood authority also raised
no objection and again this is an
indicative permeability drawing but I've
chosen to include it as you know if the
site is approved there is every chance
that this come this could come forward
given the developable areas on the sites
of agra fee these there is the pink the
green and the drawing show your site's
sealed surfaces if you like however
these surface areas are permeable and
they are complying in flood and water
terms so back to the master plan and we
now look at Access Act this is a dual
access onto Fitzgerald Road as you can
see linking north from the access points
the visibility splay is loneliness 30
mile an hour stretch are adequately
secured in a 30 mile an hour zone the
minimum requirements along the X&Y I
left them right it's 43 meters in both
directions the applicant is able to do
is able to demonstrate 70 meters in both
directions so this is why above and
beyond what your local high res
Authority would require
it's not prudent to look at connectivity
and members will relate to the site
along the southern edge Fitzgerald Road
and the closeness of a built form but
also Sosa's facilities and amenities and
I've chosen to highlight the bus stops
as well I set out in yellow this is a
sustainable location your officers have
looked at the routine bus routes and the
site is well served sustainable location
adjacent and adjoining a key service
center amongst the Ipswich fringe with
good transport options it's imperative
that sustainable development provides
the option for future owner occupiers to
use public transport and indeed
sustainable transport modes this would
be facilitated well given the bus stops
nearby and indeed the closeness of High
Street along with the shops that are
along this stretch so I'm now going to
take you through some site photos
members may wish to follow the map
bottom left corner all the site plan
master plan and the arrow the arrow is
is a guide as to where the photo was
taken from and in what direction
starting with this first photo of the
western fringe you've got the pedestrian
footpath and on the west the dwellings
with Fitzgerald Road along the north the
site is as shown view east as you can
see the site is relatively flat and
looking across the centre towards
Brantford and the most suddenly
dwellings on Fitzgerald Road
this is the public right-of-way as you
can see well-worn that leads off into
the top right-hand corner of the site
these are the dwellings along hitch toll
road taken from pretty much the center
of the site these are with two-story
form this is a view in the opposite
direction you'll see the public
right-of-way on the left-hand side of
the photo and you can see how far the
land creeped up towards the west outside
of the sign public footpath exit the
site along its railroad and I've chosen
to show you this image from what I can
find as the highest point towards the
west looking down onto the side you'll
see the site outlined in red I will just
go back you'll see the church tower
building here and basically the southern
extremity of Brantford the song isn't
greatly wooded or indeed subject to
planting within the central belly of of
the side the edges are hugely landscaped
either but there are several dense tree
and hedgerows along the western edge
uncertainly your hearts what measures
that are set out through planning
condition are endorsed by offices so I'm
going to leave you with some facts and
figures and we can revert back to this
you douche I need and it is in the
detail nine point zero eight hectare
site for up to one hundred fifteen units
thirty five percent secure for
affordable housing which are n DSS
compliant naturally described space
standard so they are good quality and
that will be set up within the section
106 the density is appropriate as well
and given the landscaping we have looked
to capture that we've got highways
compliant access and egress and also by
the water compliant management there's
also some contributions that
collectively along with other sites that
fall within the jurisdiction of Suffolk
I that all slightly into the neighboring
baby district that also have an impact
for this site and vice versa in terms of
highways contribution those elements are
captured so if this site comes forward
along with others there would be
highways contributions that would go to
mitigate through race bus stops and
highways improvements of junctions
public transport etc the early years
contribution and would be provided off
site and that's a BC is indicated filled
out your recommendation of from offices
is for approval subject to planning
conditions in section 106 it is a case
of harms against the benefits and there
would be landscape harm arising from
newly built form and on an agricultural
field there is a negligible heritage
harm also which your offices have
balanced in the overall conclusion but
the benefits are abundant new homes
which are affordable open space
building highways improvements and
landscaping and whilst the district is
able to demonstrate a five-year land
supply this isn't a ceiling height the
clear thrust from the government is to
deliver homes and I'll leave that for
now thank you yes just initial one
concerning the buses that you talked
about with talk now there's been a
sustainable location and you mentioned
bus services
mr. surprise the numbers one one one one
one I and knowing eighty eight is there
anything I feel about the nine eight
eight nine eight nine such that his
numbers indicate so the nature of those
buses secondly my belief is that the bus
service is for buses per day am i
incorrect in that that they travel
through sport in two hips which were
somewhat devious route so for parish
with about four and a half thousand
inhabitants
let's just keep it to quick questions
first question yes the bus the frequency
of the bus is we've claimed there
adequate there it's a good service what
is it and the bus numbers do two of
those indicating they're actually school
buses thanks jack so thank you for your
question um the references within the
report on the page twenty-nine to the
poor box services a take from the County
Council website in terms of what is
available the frequency of those buses I
can look into and come back to you on I
know that the frequency is supported
certainly within the apush fringe so
allow me to get back to you on the
precise times and hours of those
as if I might say you're looking for
whether it's an adequate service
considering other services that recently
been withdrawn okay so what I'm going to
do is I'm just going to run through it
in alphabetical order because like I
suspect we've got lots of you've got
questions so I'm just going to go
through an alphabetical order so Jack
are you able are you looking that up now
are you happy to take other questions
I'm happy to take questions of course I
will rather Bob size timetable well on
your answering the other questions okay
so first up is Rachel Rachel Yvette
Thank You chair I've got quite a few
questions were just trying to keep it to
three okay
the in the papers it refers to some of
the consultation documents 475 buildings
where the application is 115 so just to
double-check that the parish it's
mentioned on page 16 that the parish
plan is a material consideration and
I've not come across that before so
confirmation of that please and if I'm
only allowed three at the moment
how do what's the cycle route for pupils
going to Westbourne Academy and clayed
in high school so how will they travel
from this site to school I have got more
questions okay can you come back on
those three points to start this yes
thank you
the parish plan mentioned on page 16 so
is there there's a parish plan area but
it doesn't come part of the development
plan so is a material consideration but
which is appropriate wait a limited way
the cycle routes are referring to we'll
get back to you on
give me those another question wasn't
there with regards to something else
some of the papers supporting your hate
was bought for 75 so literally this
application came forward as 175 units
that's been reduced quite considerably
the comments are contained within have
been assessed on 15 units as well given
that this is a much lesser this game
this content is still relevant
so procedurally I'm more than happy with
the comments that are set out how they
relate to the proposal that is before
you are you for 115 units okay so
another three recharge thank you chair
on on the conditions refers to
biodiversity enhancements and also to
sustainability measures can you detail
what these are please thank you perhaps
all the recommendations on page 44 thank
you thank you
in terms of biodiversity and ecology
there are skylark mitigation measures
required as fire place Services ecology
as a means of ensuring that there would
be no net lot or indeed they would be a
net gain in terms of ecology and
biodiversity the detail of those I will
just look for now so they are the
skylight and activation plots in
accordance with the habitat regulations
that we are bound to adhere to in terms
of the sustainability measures this
we've been though with mainly at reserve
matters but it would compel the
applicants to provide sustainability
details at result of matters that would
be above and beyond what we typically
require this is in essence a
standardized and
that we've looked to adopt more recently
given a department emergency but also
what the MPPs says so what you would get
are units that would be discussed at
detail with a pre-loaded sustainability
emphasis on them in terms of open market
units and of course of border wars
migrate now come back yeah on that
thank you very much check it's just that
you say the sustainable measures
sustainability measures we'd Dell with a
reserve matters but because edition here
I just expect there to be more did more
detail and will it therefore effectively
I think there's notes on supporting page
176 would it effectively cover what's in
that the consultation feedback from um
in indeed I think sorry I will just come
back on that it's difficult to pinpoint
exactly what measures would be
introduced because we're dealing with an
outline application whereby Rhonda
Lippmann the principal and access once
the overall design and layout
orientation of buildings is known and
plots and indeed numbers we can then
look to introduce the more acute details
I think the most important part is we're
teeing the applicant up to provide
sustainability and energy measures that
are sufficient and in line with with
core policy okay thank you thank you
okay so just going alphabetically next
up is counselor field John over to you
for questions
okay just a couple more points there the
passenger transport or requirement you
mentioned a sum of hundreds of 70,000
pounds I can't find any indication of
what that's for
so wonder if you might add a bit more
clear I can see the base bus stops and
that sort of thing but they're quite
small the second question really is
about highways mitigations the route
from here into which which is down the B
10 the 67 which you can see in the
middle of the plan before you and yet
all these mitigations appear to be in
sprawling perhaps more site associated
with other developments except of call
for the cycle link on luring way which
should take children along to sup at one
so could you expand on those two things
a bit please Thank You counselor I think
it's while someone of this drawing or
image I think that is an option to going
on the B 1067 off into what would be
Bradford road heading up into lips which
outside the district and you've also got
the arterial route which is B 11 with
one three so so you have got options
whether it be you know cycling or water
or indeed by public baths that brings me
on to public transport element that
you've mentioned Suffolk County Council
highways have looked at the collective
area in terms of forgive me I'm going to
go through the drawings I've looked at
the collective area in terms of what
could be built out potentially and we do
have to plan for the future in terms of
what the site brings this is our
application site outlined as hatched in
pink outlined in orange the green dots
are approvals for the north
outside of the district as delineated by
the black line and the parish of sprawl
and in the district over the red dot is
a refusal and the orange dot is pending
application disjunction among starters
forms part of the consideration because
it is within the locality and it is
within the jurisdiction of the county
taxes the way money is spent in terms of
the public highway
obviously one hundred seventy thousand
goes to the bus improvements that would
serve this development and it would go
into a pooled part there is nothing
before members to suggest that the site
would not benefit but given there is
potential if psychomotor Hill is
psychically approved all of a sudden
you've got two more developments that
effect this I am vice versa that the
counter counts are duty-bound to
consider so we have to look at that I
think the most important part is that
these monetary contributions to upset
these concerns are included it would be
a bigger concern if they weren't the
plant plants will do have that gift this
is a consistent approach now I come in
at this point German yeah um Jack do you
have a wider aerial photograph of
anything wider than what you've got on
screen right now available I may have
yes at the start because I think is just
worth pointing out that in respect of
this development and the burden that we
are obviously seeking to mitigate in
respect of this development you need to
look a bit wider in terms of where
travel will occur as a response to any
development on this site now Brantford
has its main linkage into its which but
it doesn't link onto the a14 the
junctions it link onto the a14 is just
outside a sportin the next Junction to
get to the a14 is in Clayton so of
course that makes the B Trevor one three
the main
route if you like in terms of cars
coming off this site to get to those
relevant junctions if we were to go
further south beyond the village of
sportin you'd find that we've linked up
to what was known as War Z Grange
Pinewood an Tesco's and that is also the
[ __ ] dock interchange at that point this
route is obviously part of Suffolk
County Council strategic understanding
of how the outside of its which is going
to work in the future and obviously any
development within this corridor is is
needing to contribute towards that but
mitigate his own burden but he'll also
be part of a grander plan in terms of
understanding the transport requirements
of this side of Ipswich just to mention
while we're on this plan are you able to
point out Westbourne High School because
I believe that was a asked earlier in
respect of the vote and of course the
route to get there from Brantford would
be along the B one O six seven which is
a very standard Road it does have a
footpath among it all the way and then
of course you have to go into the
suburbia of Ipswich in order to reach
the Westport high school Clayton Clayton
High School which is in the middle of
Clayton that's a little bit more
difficult to get to you can go along the
plan for both be travel on three but it
is a 60 mile an hour Road in places and
doesn't have a footpath in you can get
along what's called paper mill Lane
which is that one there thank you that
again doesn't have any footpath among it
for the majority of it it is slower but
there are blind bends along that road so
I would have suggested that cycling is
not there are public footpaths
you can't walk to Clayton from Barth and
although it is a distance but cycling is
probably would be more for older much
older children
and adults if that was to be
participated into as an activity I would
suggest at the school bus that does run
through Barford daily well it did up
until obviously knock down those
arrangements are obviously being
reviewed at the moment but being all do
well that will be restored we'll run
through Barford and leads to Clayton for
any children as a available auction and
I'll leave it there thank you thank you
John did you have any further questions
can I just come in uh I can only see
slide 22 so the whole of that
conversation does not relate to the
slide that I can see on my screen I
might think something different from
everybody else I can only see 22 so
something's gone wrong what am I doing
wrong
well you're not we have one slide in
front of us you took your head your
screen frozen no that's why I'm asking
I'm completely confused I'm completely
out of it said that so what is in front
of you at the moment slide 22 which says
bus stops okay so Jack can you take the
screen down and then we would get take
it down and then put it up again please
put the screen back up again
okay so what you saying that loading
I now see slide four but unfortunately I
was at a loss so I'm afraid I may of
missed applause so John can you just go
to the relevant page and just just give
a summary again just I think it's better
that we're clear okay more than one job
sorry sorry John Feynman gee okay so I
was saying that comes I tend to talk and
not think about what I'm talking about
right let me start again so I was saying
that if we look at the overall picture
of Barford in its setting - its which
and I did get us to a plan that was
indicating where the Junction's were so
ultimately any development in Brantford
is likely to need access to the a14 well
but itself doesn't have access to the
a14 so you have to either go through the
villagers Wharton to get to the
interchange which has been indicated at
the moment by Jack or you need to go
north and go to the interchange at
Claydon the alternative option is to go
all the way south through the village of
sportin and into essentially it's- which
we have pine wood and Tesco's and the
[ __ ] rock interchange is also new
development there that is regardless as
well as he Grange within the weber
district in terms of the so we were
talking about the strategic
contributions that would be looking at
that entire corridor between Claydon
and the War Z Grange and cock-block
interchange because it's all
interconnected due to the triple 1-3
going into its which itself along the
106 seven that is the way you'd go to
get to Westbourne high school which is
just indicated there you then go into
the network of them suburbia it's which
to get to the school there is a good
footpath there is a good road in order
to go along
which is I'm not aware of any issue
particularly in that respect to get to
Clayton is more problematic because you
have to go either along the football on
three which is a road that doesn't have
a foot way all the way around just about
there with actual there's no footpath
there and I do know that from personal
experience because I used to bike a long
way in order to get to needle market we
do then get the Clayton but the other
root is paper mill lane again that
doesn't have any foot way so a cyclist
would be on the road for the majority of
it and both of those roads are perhaps
not so suitable as going into loops
which where they are slower traffic
speeds and wider say to roads and
however there is a bus service that goes
through Branford and he's a regular bus
service for hits and that is available
when put on by a Suffolk County Council
thank you alright Sarah um is there
anything I need to do to make sure it
doesn't happen to go a couple of
messages up shouting in the end sorry
okay so John then you finished with your
questions next we go on to was not
entirely finished I was just pointing
out that the questions and I was trying
to ask questions were what was the
hundred and seventy thousand appearances
at Jack's fault for I can see the small
samples but what was the bulk of it for
yeah I could come to what I'd like it to
be for but I don't know what it's
actually for the second question really
in a way John penguin Diaz as a sort of
Illustrated which is that the highways
mitigation I would expect to help pupils
and people you know people who've done
Drive perhaps people don't wish to drive
get in and out of it quick as well as
access the a14 in both directions and I
have to sound lived here for 30 years
without knowing where those junctions
are it just looking at the highway
mitigation there's a cycle link on
Lorraine rye which is from Brantford to
scroll and that heads to stop at one
good but the vast the majority yeah out
of cash is things like zebra crossing at
the Wildman great for the pub I'm sure
and reduce curb radii in somewhere I
know not where and bottom okay but speak
around but the issue is what are these
things that we 107 mm thank you
essentially this goes into the pulled
part that is within the jurisdiction of
the County Council and I wholly
understand your concerns of where that
goes but I must stress that this is
largely dependent also on whether it is
needed given the other developments
within the locality that were outlined
earlier so highways mitigation subsidy
curves except that may be required this
would fall under the the wrongs of a
section 2 7 8 Agreement the crucial
factor here is that we as additional
council are securing it and the County
Council would be delivering it through
section 2 7i that's all that I can give
you at this moment in time thank you
jack okay we now move on to castle
housing in the vignette do you have any
questions
I don't thank you casler sir mantle
you're next Sarah
Thank You chair I also have a number of
questions so if I if I do three now and
then I'll think about the first one is
we were told at the beginning of the
presentation this is twin tracker
application and I just wondered if that
had any significance or any implications
presumably it means that they are both
identical and we have to determine both
of them I'm not I'm not quite sure of it
has any other implications that's my
first question second question is about
the early years provision because I
think the paperwork is a little bit
confusing on page 38 38 know of
lost a piece of paper one of our bits of
paper says that there is a early years
building on
site but on page 39 we have some
information about early years and
infrastructure provision and it says
that it will be subject to early years
education contribution I intersection
17.1 in section 18 point one it says
additional preschool places at existing
establishments so is or is there or is
there not a earliest building on this
site and my other question is about the
it's possibly to do with the fact that
there was a previous application but
some of our papers have an indicative
master plan which shows housing in the
far south of the plot and and then we
have a slide which shows that as the
open space so can we be quite clear that
we're looking at the indicative layout
which has the open space at the bottom
of it yes Thank You councillor the twin
tracker is the form that the applicant
was chosen to submit through so we have
two applications are to be determined
today both are you are correct identical
with the only difference being the
references the site is identical the
early years element is an element that
would be secured off-site there isn't a
provision on site and the funding for
the provision built to BC is standard
would be secured through section 106
having consulted the development
contribution as manager at the counts
Council in terms of also apologies for
the confusion within the papers that is
most definitely off-site based upon the
school places needed and the costs
associated the final question was to do
with the master plan this is the
indicative master plan as you can see
which is on
5:14 some answer can you see that
counselor answer can you yeah I've got
slide 14 it's just that we have some
other slides in our paperwork which had
a different indicative master plan I
think yes
page 231 this is the proposed master
plan and the elements that are
considered are set out as per and we
relying upon slide 14 for that purpose
chops that's clear chair thank you
can I cut back on another couple of
queries we were told that the density
was twelve point seven or something like
that
now does that include that large area of
open space I'm assuming not presumably
that 12.7 dwellings per hectare is over
the whole site including that open space
and I'm sorry I'm not very good at Road
names in the Ipswich fringe can somebody
just point out to me on a map where the
rainway is thank you questions all
that's included are you once live 32 km
and so I am thank you very much
perfect so the third notch down is a
quantum mix of the tax no touching
terraced houses you've got a gross and
net dwellings per hectare both of which
are compliant with policy so when you
include at all not include the open
space as a whole or just a developable
area both are within compliance and
you'll add a question about Lorraine why
I'll just get to Lorraine why is the
travel 1/3 indeed
so it's this road here extends all the
way up though so where is the cycleway
going all the way from this site to
where it goes all the way to suffolk one
which is a college on the edge of
Pinewood in Ipswich in the district of
or Baber so you have in essence Narayan
way the b11 one three you can see the
rain won't marker there to the north
I'll go to another image sorry that's
better
so they've played in rocket Road and it
leads up from here all the way down
through past the side through sportin
and you may know the crossroads while
grandpa and off into the edge of each
switch so that links off the cycle ring
thank you sorry Matthew mileage is
correct that slightly yeah unless
anybody now is better the sixty thousand
pound cycle path goes from the top of
Fitzgerald Road the point more or less
where that red marker is and it goes
down to the wild man who's brought is
already a footpath along there and it
modifies that we'll be good to go the
rate and it's possible to go the rest
but I don't believe that actually is
covered with that sum of money thank you
for that John that so it's just a short
stretch along that beat rebel 1/3 from
Brantford to just Broughton that this
development is going to provide to an
existing an existing cycle way from
Sprott to Suffolk one
there's there's the option to do that I
can't give you that answer because we're
not in charge or the County Council
function ultimately the section 270-a
agreement that County Council choose to
implement would provide detail on that
okay okay so any other questions at all
think that's it for now something else
may come to mind later no no yeah
Casa Matheson do you have any questions
I do thank you yes yes I D I must say
the the presentation was excellent the
one thing that wasn't there that I was
looking for subsequently surface as
slide 41 and I think it'd be helpful you
could get that one back again and I did
really want to understand the the
relationship with the other a nearby
development so sorry well applications
etc that John pavement he was speaking
about but I wanted to understand them
particularly in the context of the
paragraph six point six six point seven
and six point eight these these discuss
the for travel mitigation amounts of
money conditions etc and yeah yeah
absolutely what what is what is worrying
me that either is not clear is the this
this development that we're looking at
the moment delivers some amounts of
money for towards contribution towards
these schemes the four schemes that are
listed as a pair are six point seven and
the six-point a discusses the sequence
in which they might be delivered
depending on the other
so I really like to understand a bit
more about that because the I would
admit I was expecting that the six point
six seems to be looking for the list of
those developments which compound which
is now gone through hopefully all of the
relevant ones so if if they don't all go
forward and certainly at the moment
we're saying we've got one refusal and
one okay
Thank You chair I think the most
important part is is to patent well
effectively if all sites were delivers
this site will come through appeal this
site is yet to be determined
which I trust you can see 541 yes good
and the most important part is that if
all is a possibility then there needs to
be that link open you know you can
activity made the most important part is
that these elements are captured and yes
this particular that we are here to
determine hashed in pink would
contribute to the sites at the north and
to the south and vice versa if schemes
are approved outside of the district in
Weber then pulled some of money from
both sides and upshot towards the
crop-top interchange where Tesco is
those skins would contribute to this
game so you all have collective input
it's a cumulative effect the most
important part is that it's included
rather than not included clear yet the
my reading of paragraph six point eight
which starts off saying the improvements
require all the developments to come
forward and society
you can see that's quite possibly not
going to happen is that the it seems as
if the cycle link is is the the last one
that would come forward in other words
if any if any of the applications that
have currently been refused etc don't
happen then in cycle link is the first
thing that can block and I would be
concerned at that I get that but you do
see I want to understand exactly where
saying it's a sequence sorry Jo I just
want to hopefully a bit clearer
the bullets listed at para six point
seven are not sequential not ordered by
I'll just listed the important part is
that these four elements these four
bullet points I would be considered by
the local horizon
there is no guarantee that the fourth on
it ie new cycle link between Sprott and
umber Alfred would be lot first there's
no guarantee of that at all we would be
in the hands and the jurisdiction of the
County Council Thank You chef have you
ever questioned in front yeah I think
the other thing which count summary
burners as has touched upon already is
that you know can we be sure that the
the entirety of infarct Wilson's
proposed condition these will be
contained within the sustainability
measures condition the wording yeah of
course I think we've adopted a more of a
standardized salinity measures condition
good which I trust you're aware of and
this is you know common with certainly
major applications that we've adopted in
in the past few months so yes we could
improve our good thank you that's all
for now okay thank you drunk next
/ - cap sir richer mayor reappear
thanks yeah just a lot of questions um
the page 1 to 1 this is there are most
separate places in the local primary
school or secondary schools and that
very significant still funds would be
required to enhancer are those funds
going to be available and will the
schools be enhanced or expanded to cope
with the increased demands if this
assignment gets approved
thank you a question
Casa mayor I think the duty of care and
certainly there is a duty within the
County Council function and is that
school places must be provided whether
that's at the primary school with an
asset nearby secondary schools or
whether there's a bus provision if
there's no space this has been trashed
out there he'll on quite a few occasions
it's a very difficult topic to stand up
if you like the most important part is
that the County Council have to provide
school places and certainly the sill
funding and the sills and injection
would go a long way to provide them are
so sill is included and the bit of where
is it five hundred and forty five
thousand pounds cerca that would go some
way to divide so those feel funds will
be available and then expanding that
into the healthcare is there any still
provision to expand the health services
in the area which I know are under 71
below what they should be already come
in and ultimately the sill you committee
infrastructure levy is a pot and that
pot will be you know distributed in
accordance with the council's
infrastructure plan
and that obviously plan gets worked up
between the District Council and the
County Council in terms of the NHS as
well you know they are can bid for money
as they see fit for expansion or
improvements to care within the area
just as with schools and you know we are
you
the aerial and because we are close we
switch there is a fair choice don't have
the capacity to expand now as I do live
in this direction I do know that most of
these schools do have good capacity and
land available to them to expand if
necessary obviously being coastal mixes
well there are various choices in terms
of doctors and and getting care and
clinics and so forth also available and
it would be for the NHS trusts to just
be cheap monies accordingly through any
sill bid they might make thank you not a
question specifically acacia Hicks but I
can provide some clarification to the
question raised by John field earlier
regarding the public transport he is
correct there are already four buses at
the present but because the early bus
seriously he stole market lips which by
Brantford was withdrawn last year
thank you okay
so anyone else any further questions yes
please yeah yeah who's this Sarah okay I
do have another question on our
indicative layout which I believe is
slide 12 of our papers I can't remember
if it's the same one on the presentation
which is I admit is only an indicative
housing mix but the numbers at the
bottom of that slide for the open
markets dwellings do not tally with the
strategic housing needs which were on
page 142 of our report and I wondered if
anything had been said or discussed
about the open market housing mix
if I may come in on this particular
point um in terms of affordable housing
member members will find or see in our
recommendation that the application will
be subject to a section 106 agreement
and the affordable housing mix is
detailed they're in full in terms of
both property sizes bedrooms and size of
property so we have that is completely
open and transparent in respect of this
application we have not and I'm
double-checking and will correct me if
I'm wrong we have not sought to secure
the market housing mix in respect to
this application I think that's what I
can say thank you Alesis yeah so we're
now going to move on thank you members
and we now move on where we ask the
parish council representative to speak
and we have Diane strand is going to
speak down you have three minutes and up
on the screen shortly we'll come a timer
with indicate for you the three minutes
give it one second
just checking are you there Donna yes I
am okay so you can see in front of you
there's a 3-minute timer it just gives
you an indication as you speak the timer
will start so over to when you're ready
thank you
Thank You chair I just wanted to start
by saying Bradford parish councils been
consistent in its concerns over these
proposals but has also tried to be fair
and objective in its responses and I
hope that comes across to the committee
it's also taking into consideration the
huge swell of public opinion in what
appears to be a significant objection to
this proposal and supports the parish in
there and just which I just wish to
briefly reiterate what concerns the
parish councillors have previously
raised ie
is it a sustainable development with
regard to the National Planning policy
framework there is significant
development currently underway or
approved for approximately 300 dwellings
at the other end of the village it's
been
and already made suffix five-year land
supply is that relevant and whether
these proposals satisfy certain
strategic objectives are you protecting
the environment supporting strong and
healthy communities and infrastructure
we've spoken about the buses being
reduced the public rights-of-way through
the center of the development and
further information from highways as to
the potential effects of the decision to
close Brantford Lane recently made
suffice to say the parish councils
response did refer to a proposal for 13
houses on the site made back in 2002
it's believed that some of these reasons
for refusal are still relevant today was
described as a visual intrusion to the
detriment of the rural character this is
the only remaining view of some of
bravas most historic buildings in the
church which is great one listed it was
described as a car centric development
with issues regarding the access on to
and from fitzgerald roads due to the
sharp end one end and Park Hill on the
road probably now exacerbated by
significantly increased number of cars
on the road over 20 years and then
there's the desire by Suffolk Council
Suffolk County Council at the time to
retain the character and future use of
public rights-of-way
a sentiment still echoed today with the
County Council's desire to improve the
access to green spaces it's hoped the
committee will take into account these
issues when considering these proposals
thank you very much thank you very much
okay members do we have any questions
for the parish council
I have one yes counselor Mansell again I
would just like to ask the parish
council representative if there has been
any communication consultation whatever
the word is between the developer and
the Parish Council on this application
never hasn't thank you
parish basically the sustainable
transport into it which is the current
situation satisfactory to the residents
of the village now it hasn't been for a
while a meeting last year when the 89
bus was withdrawn generated 50 residents
attending the meeting and there's still
been no resolution as to what's going to
replace it at this time okay any other
questions no thank you so we're now
going to move on thank you very much
next we move on to an objector Caroline
Walton Caroline again do you have three
minutes to address the committee and
again you'll have the timer the speed
reset for you there we go
okay and over to you are you there yes
thank you chairman thank you you'll see
from your reports our residents feel
strongly about this development and on
our greenfield site that lies outside
the village boundary 597 objections have
been sent to you across the two
applications by our community expressing
their concerns the village of Brantford
have had two planning approval of 512
Wellings since 2015 which is a 48%
increase in housing with two large
developments to the north of the village
of 325 dwellings which are still under
construction this development is for a
further 115 homes to the south
Sheila 2019 states branchless to provide
295 dwellings the local planning
authority is to
is able to demonstrate that it as an
adequate five-year housing land supply
is not identified at the Paris plan and
is located outside of the defined
settlement boundary
therefore this development is beyond
policy requirement and not currently
needed the site must also be considered
in context of a multitude of sites along
the dipping Valley corridor contributing
to massive cumulative growth and an
almost continuous ribbon of development
along with the travel 1/3 these sites
show a clear demonstration of creeping
coalescence of ribbon development which
the MPPs specifically warns against
place Services landscape report states
the views will be adversely impacted
upon as a result of the development the
special landscape area and views at the
Gipping Valley Riverwalk would be
greatly affected along with the footpath
that cuts across this site with views of
the grade 1 listed church and Gipping
Valley policy CS 5 states it will
protect and conserve landscape qualities
this development does not it will be an
ever tool change to the character of the
existing agricultural land causing
landscape harm the wider heritage views
will be effective and affected and
Suffolk Preservation Society states and
Mary's Church and Street Farm Cottage
listed buildings are still at risk and
recommend a further reduction of
dwellings in line with Sheila and shot
and JLP the site had planning
application for 13 dwellings refused in
2002 as mentioned by the Clark and it
was refused due to the detriment of the
rural character and appearance of the
area it again shows that this
development 115 dwellings is not
appropriate on this site as 13 were
confused this field performs many
functions for wildlife recreation flood
risk and food production it is of huge
value to the community and should not be
used for housing development when other
sites are available Brantford has the
brownfield site of items on paper Mill
Lane
this site is sustainable and ready for
development and PPF State's development
of available brown seals field sites
must be completed as a priority before
Greenfield is considered many thanks
thank you very much
do we have any questions at all or
members yeah I have Java yeah okay yeah
you you mentioned right in the middle of
your comments the the MPPs I wonder what
paragraph that wasn't whether officers
can help us with with that little more
to which which point is being made in
the MPPs thank you I'm terribly sorry I
don't have the paragraph available
obviously I could look that up okay John
or Jack can you which question that the
questioner coalescent saw the question
of brown field versus green field I
think it was it was the Carroll essence
point actually give me a moment or I'm
the pilot there with me just look at
myself
and he's sign oh I just had a look John
and I'm not sure whether you've found
anything but coalescence isn't really
discussed within the MP pen so there's
no word to that effect I know that
there's case law that's come out from
South Norfolk with regards to settlement
coalescence and it comes down to it's a
stressful time on landscape grains and
whether the coalescence would be way too
close to the body of another settlement
or indeed another village
I think the coalescence aspect is an
important part that we certainly have
considered because it's a poignant
matter
I think the separation distance between
Brantford and sprawl and is adequate
more than adequate given the stretch
along the Rhine why John have you got
anything to add on that I'm still
looking and I will continue to look I
can't find anything either
obviously I'm looking also at the
section within the NPP F about Greenbelt
but of course that applies to be
Greenbelt and Augie people often take
that out of context I do recall in terms
of mid Suffolk one of the debates about
coalescence was where we have stone
market and Stowe upland but that
literally was half of the half a field
between the village boundary and stone
market Cedars part development in this
case I either there is a a greater
distance but Barry I think we need to
move on and if I could find something I
can certainly bring that to a members
attention okay next up we have an
opportunity for a supporter to speak but
we have no supporters come forward and
just checking there's no supporter who's
come in no okay
next we now ask the applicant Chris
Smith to speak again you have three
minutes to address the committee and
we'll just be resetting the timer
are you there Chris morning chairman yes
okay over to you
Thank You chairman members my name's
Chris Smith on development planet
Hopkins Holmes has been outlined by your
offices the site lies in a wholly
sustainable location on the edge of the
settlement of Brantford within walking
distance of a good range of local
services and facilities and forms a
draft local plan allocation with the
unit within the emerging joint local
plan through positive working with your
offices since the application
submissions in the spring of last year
the requirements of all statutory
consort EES are now able to be fully
addressed that's enabling your officers
to be confident that their proposals
will provide a high quality to stand
well new development within an
attractive landscape setting forming a
positive visual enhancement to this
southern entrance to the village as
you've heard the proposals will deliver
up to 150 new dwellings which up to 40
will be affordable homes in full
accordance with existing policy in
association there will be over 4
hectares of new public open space
alongside all the requested financial
contributions towards other essential
infrastructure by the sale and section
106 procedures in summary therefore we
trust that you can come comparable with
your office's recommendation and that
you're able to support the proposals
Thank You chairman and as always I'm
happy to answer any questions that
members may have thank you to members I
guess the first one is from me around
engagement with the parish council yes
were present coming up for two years ago
now when the concept of the development
was put forward and obviously members of
the parish council and indeed local
residents had the opportunity to to have
their say we had a very good turnout to
that event and obviously there are a
variety of opinions offered and some
some more positive than others are on
their faces we then took the application
forward to where we are now we are happy
to engage we know why didn't this run
I think it was it was great at the
parish council weren't in favor of
development principle and on that basis
it's difficult then to have a positive
dialogue but say we've we've not just
gone to the parish council with we've
held an event locally where why you
chose to not get involved with the
parish council because we always find
that this committee that if parish
council is engaged with the app and you
get a much better decision-making
process but obviously so you made a
decision you do not want to engage with
the parish council because they weren't
supportive that's the answer
we've always been open to dialog with
the parish council but we see they don't
make their position clear so there isn't
there's not been the opportunity really
to to to engage further in that respect
door was always open and we're happy to
talk to to anyone exactly the same their
doors always open okay so you chose not
to go to the project canceled thank you
any other questions yes I have one yeah
just about the indicative plans I always
find these slightly uncomfortable and
one understands the principle perhaps
but we have a range of indicative plans
here which we're told the one on screens
the right one we have in the past often
ask developers whether they were
prepared to see a condition that says
essentially the development should be
broadly in line with or essentially in
line with the indicative plan just to
make sure that we haven't boast our
opinions on a load of make-belief yeah
in terms of yes certainly the indicative
band that's on the screen before you now
has evolved over time through the
process to the application and
consultation with your offices and as
your officer said with your councils
landscape consultants our intention
would be to bring forward a reserved
matters detailed application that
broadly Accords with with that layer and
obviously in putting this lay out in the
public domain people will write the
expect
- there any reserve matters fairly
closely aligns with with what's shown on
the plan here
so you'd agree with a condition yes I
don't see a problem with a condition
worded don't you know any any reserved
matters submission should broadly align
with the detail shown on this indicative
layout because you know the end of the
day we're not here to join um try and
try and come forward with something
different you know we're trying to
establish at this point in time a layout
that we feel would that we could build
to an accept me no mistake and and
indeed a high-quality appearance in an
informant scale and figure with the
character the locality in the area and
indeed in accord with the the main
things on here no one here the lines
that are showing in terms of views to
the church views through to the special
landscape here in the river alignment at
the public footpath and and guess we'd
like to to be able to come forward with
a layout that that you know does accord
with that so I've not got a problem with
the condition to that effect none I just
got one on the Crescent I just asked her
obviously under the recommendations and
not papers on page 44 45 it talks about
obviously the affordable housing at 5%
can you confirm that you won't be coming
back with a further application to
change that that that will actually stay
as is in the future yes chairman I don't
see any reason why we should need to do
that you know we've had discussions with
the offices it's an outline up to 115
dwellings we feel that 115 dwellings can
be accommodated on here and therefore
that's why we've had this indicative
layout to try and show her that could be
achieved and within that there the the
requested amount and layer of affordable
housing should be deliverable so I don't
see that there should be any needs
because I just think about - frowning
and when you
there's economic downturn and you went
back and train check out the Affordable
so your view is that the Affordable here
and the shared ownership will stay in
place even if there is econ downturn yes
chairman I mean it just for other
members reference the farming and so it
was the brownfield site that had asked
additional costs over and above what
would normally be anticipated this is as
you've heard a Greenfield previously
undeveloped site so there should be no
reason for us to come back on that point
great thank you for that okay any other
questions no okay thank you very much
for that thank you
okay we now move on to the ward member
cancer James Caston James over to you
thank you very much mr. chairman as you
will see this application has a huge
amount of public objections and comments
this is actually nine times more
objections than the the Willowbrook and
semuc sites which were a hundred 85 and
115 dwellings it's more than those put
together for this one this one side of
115 houses this goes to show that the
residents of Brantford are open-minded
to development but this particular one
is completely unacceptable to them
whenever I've spoken to residents in
Brantford the Fitzgerald development has
been a major issue throughout the
village this application was considered
seriously damaging by most residents
this is also my position on it
I feel the development is completely
unacceptable for the position which I'll
talk about a bit further the whilst
against lost against Fitzgerald Road
there is a site development at the
Bisons on paper Mill Lane the Bisons
area this is one of the last arable
fields visible and usable and accessible
to the residents so I'm going to talk
now a bit about the quality of land in
the planning application there was a
land grade assessment the field is
downgraded to a grade 2 because of its
intolerance to drought this is because
it's free drainage in the expected crop
and land use survey it is designated as
76 suitable for cereals sugar beet and
other arable crops some fruit and
horticultural crop this all tends to dry
out but in the in the pictures which I
think are quite useful you can see how
green those summer
fields are it lays in the perfect
position for irrigation of high-value
crops which would bring it as good as
any grade one land which of course we
know mid Suffolk does not have any grade
one land in the in its whole area what
better position for use of water that is
drained away from them pendulum in the
future in a future that will be safer
the need for water and this attenuation
attenuated water can be used for
something useful the in the winter time
the sugar beet with some lifted off his
field and it was cultivated within days
I don't think any young farmers would
disagree that this was a terrible year
and probably the hardest in a generation
for lifting sugar beets and and at
working land it was so incredibly wet it
is now a really respectable spring
barley field which is in itself
incredible considering we didn't have
any rain during the whole of April of
May in Branford this is some this is
field is delivering food into the market
in a year where most fields have really
struggled
the only real issue for this field
I can imagine is the grazing of the wild
fell going into the river because it's
um it backs onto the floodplain as you
know the the only the area of the
stirrin or well s tourism special
protection is adjacent to the site and
it's an incredibly special world life
corridor taking more farmland away from
this will not deliver the biodiversity
net game you were taking the type of
land that is an asset to a wild fell and
wildlife associated with the river and
replacing it with gardens and that
Harbor a very different type of
biodiversity a biodiversity that is not
needed by a river if you had domestic
cats and dogs barking into the mix which
I'm okay and dog owner myself I haven't
got a problem with it you will find that
these creatures have a much harder time
surviving this is the second to last
arable field that lies between the beach
rebel 1/3 or Lorraine way and be 1067
which is the paper mill Lane and
Brantford Road either side of the
village it's the only arable field you
can now see as you drive home from
Ipswich from your drivers side it's it's
the only arable field with a footpath
that leads to sprawl turn and then it's
which it is iam it's a route taken by
the local gyms and running clubs they
can still use it but they'll be running
in an urbanized environment the people
of Brantford drive out of its which can
come home to the incredible view of the
special landscape area with the grade 1
listed mates saint mary's church and the
amazing backdrop of historic woodland
and they're reminded that they live in
village and not a suburb and you can see
from the photos there I don't know which
side it was but it has some really good
photos of that incredible view
Branford has resistor being swallowed up
into it's which over the years and it
just tried to include it but it remains
mid suffered a resident told me recently
they are very proudly mid Suffolk it's a
rural village and must be it must not be
incorporated into her town not the
identity of the village building further
towards the boundary of sportin is
destroying that that village identity
building building further towards that
boundary as well is the definition of
coalescence this will leave only a small
field between the development and the
border of Baber which is an issue
because we will no longer have any
control over stopping these and village
has been linked together and potentially
risking in boundary changes losing the
economic value of Brantford and to
another district so the land is
productive and it's a definite loss with
and a lot of opportunities for the
future I don't believe is a there's a
net gain for biodiversity it damages the
village identity the the loss of that
field into urbanization Natural England
so that this application is likely to
have significant effect and I totally
agree the visual amenity in the view
from beat the beat Ripper one three or
Lorraine way and the footpath will be
gone forever and it sits outside the
settlement boundary housing supplies
another issue I'd like to raise we've
recently had large developments approved
that go along the beach at one 395 how's
the semuc site which is not built yet
which adds to seven
fifty-four dwellings on this road into a
switch the recent approval of the snow
Asus complex adds to the weight of
traffic on the a14 the implication on
highways a yet unknown Brantford is
already providing homes and has recently
had the willow Brook development which
is over a hundred new homes with
thirty-five affordable houses the
semak's site will deliver another
forty-five I'm happy to say that we've
taken tenants from other areas of mid
suffered as we shared and I am pleased
that we have assisted in the overall
need for affordable housing in the
district but these we don't need these
houses right on our border we are
actually two point six four point two
kilometres from the a14 so we had
nowhere near a fourteen corridor most of
the traffic goes through the bottleneck
of Sprott and there isn't it there is no
one footpath on the beach every 1-3
Paper Mill Lane and the highway
mitigation control does not deal with
any of these issues all there sorry we
have the in let's see the GP surgeries
sorry the Theban surgeries for the
Chesterfield Drive surgeries for Barham
surgery has 3,200 patient capacity in
his full most of the Brantford residents
are directed towards the norwich road
surgery in Ipswich they Emma we do not
have time to catch up with this amount
of building happening them so quickly
the secondary schools are the secondary
school is for Brantford primary has just
been extended to deal with the
development that's going on at the
moment
Broughton school is summer full as well
these I just don't believe that we can
grow
this quickly and deal with those issues
that are happening there in 2002 a much
smaller development was turned down on
the site is 13 dwellings and as you will
all know Baber also turned down am a
similar development on the other side of
the of the road the the I urge the
committee to run to refuse this
application and thank them for their
time very much accustomed any questions
it's really it could be genuine really
is if on the large map point out with a
Feist insight is in relating to this and
also there's no aces site
I believe the five-cent site runs
alongside we've taken a lane which comes
to class time surely be able to correct
me if I'm wrong I believe it's down here
approximately yes I would say that's
about where it is yeah it's just where
the road kinks mr. bill imbalance it
which I remember it's where where
they're close to the road I would
suggest okay okay and then the sugar
cube if you like is located on bottom in
the road rights is here just opposite me
roundabout as you were doing so play
there's no asa site please as snow as
society's office until John where it
says Claydon where Branford road
branches so uh and now left left left
left
is there okay thanks very much okay
thank you any other questions for Jones
no ok so members we've had all the
information put before us we've had all
the details we've obviously had a a
large pack and it's able to us now to
discuss debate and to come to a
conclusion so happy to if I may be do it
in order in order just run through
alphabetical order again if everyone's
happy that's probably makes most sense
so I start off with you Rachel
Thank You chair council reborn' speaking
I thank you everybody for your
contributions to this presentation this
morning that's all very clear and thank
you jack
Dipsy for the presentation with regards
to this particular site and we
appreciate it's on the edge of the
settlement boundary but if it is right
close to them to the village and the
applicant has you know from their
initial application of 175 reduced it to
115 and I think you know keeping the
provided that indicative layer does stay
which I think the applicant has said
that they would adhere to in the end of
the conditions to keep that large amount
of open space in the proximity of the
river Gipping would be very beneficial
and I do debate somewhat the
agricultural land provides one life
areas because I think actually it you
know the hedgerows and so on may do but
not so much the actual agricultural land
with God's the skiing there one of the
things that I am still concerned about
is the access for walking and cycling
and so I would wander chair if when it
gets to conditions if if the committee
were minded to approve that whether we
can have some kind of informative or
some kind of condition ensuring that the
cycle conditions are kept as a priority
within that section 278 agreement but
I'd be interested to hear what others
say but I mean it's from what I can see
you know it is right on the edge of the
village the village has got very good
amenities with the conditions providing
better you know enhancing the bus
transport and so on
that should help mitigate some of some
of the issues there but I wait to hear
what the rest of my colleagues say thank
you chair
Thank You chair yes I had to say I'm
normally in favor of developments and
indeed this you know is well related to
the age of Brantford and the facilities
within the village however I do find the
very strong objections that have been
present for a long time back to the days
of the village plan really need to carry
significant white there's a very large
number centres of population strongly
against this a local plan emerging local
plan joint local plans discourages
coalescence of villages and I understood
well that was why this was withdrawn
recently and the lump of housing at the
southern extreme as I said it the map
disappeared at the southern extreme was
withdrawn so there's considerable
concern there
the actual growth in the village as I
think the objective pointed out 190 130
another 90 down of license 20 ordered
the bypass nursery saw it and this
hundred which I've seen is getting to be
a very large percentage growth for what
is a substantial village but not
enormous Soloff on that can
disconcerting perhaps the most
significantly to me however is the
transport I can't see at the moment that
the time that it's sustainable really
really carries white bus services have
been with reduce drastically from so one
an hour or more down to one every two
and a half hours and that was both
services used to run simultaneously so
we have a reduction in an area where
people expect to use public transport to
commute into its which a lot of them
work there a lot of them shop they're so
strong problem they are also a strong
problem for pupils going to school
the foot why propose my improve access
to suffer mill and needs considerably
more cash attached to it to do that but
if that's a good possibility but access
to Westbourne and to Claydon is is not
good for pedestrians
therefore parts are constantly in poor
condition constantly need work to
maintain their width and there are
hazards on the way so I find overall
with some worry perhaps I really am
against this application as he's usually
said that I would listen to others and
thank you um I'm a little bit um torn
focus I'm on paper it seems that
everything's right you know it's I mean
it's to me it's sustainable I think a
bus service every two hours be fantastic
around here but I can say that's um
that's my opinion about sustainable bus
routes but it does look you know the
density is good the house size is good
they've got all the the 35% affordable I
can say on paper don't look none of
their console tees have objections but
seems to be against it is is is a really
strong thing in my mind and um and
although Rachel things that the like I'm
James said it provides food and it's
generally an absolute disaster but um
anyway so like say a little bit torn but
you know I can see the benefit thank you
next up we kicked out but bothers me
yeah I having him I think that the
change from in a number of housing 475
215 years of positive keeping the
riverbanks and that area clear I agree
passive of that does I think make a
significant difference all of them in
Suffolk I think is grade 2 or grade 3 on
the land front it does to me feel like a
sustainable
the density is about right and we've
heard commitment that the essential for
ball will stay which I think really
important to have a thought was
particularly in this part of our
district I'm hoping that the housing
might cause increased use of buses and
we've seen the cycleway
you know putting something towards a
cycle where as important and that's
something you know we were encouraging
more and more missing water more
interest in cycling so and while the
problem is on the other side it has few
numbers of opposition you've got the
board member who spoke very eloquently
about all the local concerns and the
issues that have been raised but at the
moment I'm struggling to find enough any
reasons really that I could refuse it
because I think that they're more
reasons for approval at this stage but
happy to keep listing to others okay
said that this councilor matter Thank
You chair
I am listening with great interest to my
colleagues because I to a bit sitting on
the fence with this application at the
current time I can see all the arguments
that it is in a sustainable location it
is only about five kilometers cycle ride
to it's switch station and you know we
do need to encourage more people that's
a good distance as any you know a
relatively easy distance
cycle we should be able to encourage
people to use more sustainable modes of
transport and unfortunately we as a
district council have nothing really to
do about the buses it is sad but they
are being cut down at this time and I I
do have a lot of sympathy with the
community but we're all very aware that
this isn't the only village that is
being forced to take on large
development sites which significantly
increase the size of the community but
you know we have to remember that that
is actually government policy that we
need this many houses I think it's very
disappointing that there hasn't been a
very much engagement between the
developer and the parish council apart
from a single consultation about
years ago which is probably soon
forgotten by a lot of people I was very
interested to hear the board members
comments about the agricultural land
because one of the things I have picked
up on this application as with others is
looks like about half of this site it's
great too
even with the grading that he commented
on a half is great too and we as we know
in itself don't have a lot of great to
cultural land there are clearly concerns
about the landscape and a bit of the
heritage in terms of views of the church
and things and it will be a great loss
really to the area that we don't get
that lovely view from that road over the
over the Gipping Valley we you know will
be changed so you know there are you
know it is on the edge of the village
it's very close to its switch it just
seems that there hasn't been a bit of a
more proactive approach to to working
with the parish council to actually find
some things that they would like to have
out of this community at this
development now the only concern I have
with with one of the comments has been
made about the the fact that the
developer seems willing to have a
condition imposed about the development
being broadly in line with his
indicative plan which we've got on slide
12 I'm a bit concern that if we take
that too far I'm not happy with the
market housing mix guys later on that
says thing oddly like doesn't include me
I suggested marking housing mix I
probably be you know if I if I head down
the way of agreeing with this then I'm
not I think we need to make sure their
wording of that that new condition is
it's very careful carefully worded thank
you thank you cast an answer for that
okay next is cancer Matheson
yes this this certainly ought to be a
sustainable location as Sarah said
within such short distance of hips which
and at some point I'm sure I'm sure that
it will be a sustainable location but
unfortunately you know I I have to ask
myself can you live there and be
economically active without a car and
the answer unfortunately seems to have
headed from yes to no with the loss of
the buses I mean I think the you know
broadly the the amount of buses
available is probably dropped by
two-thirds or something without knowing
the precise timetables an hour II
service is good that means you you can
get to places roughly when you need to
and for a day you can't get where you
need to be in any reasonable way so that
is a big problem and the same really
goes for the the cycling it's it's nice
to see bits of it being brought forward
but people who need to cycle to its
which do need a continuous and and
tolerably safe route to cycle you know
when all that when that stuff's there
I'd have no hesitation this would be an
open-and-shut case
oh dear I think I just had a internet
problem okay I just had to drop out and
come back in but I missed everything
that John Matheson said sorry okay
John's basically said that he doesn't do
this the cycle routes aren't strong
enough he doesn't think it is a
sustainable location and those are the
sort of key points to the stage but John
batty is Sarah there yes I think I think
the other the other the other
[ __ ] the chairs as reiterated to the
point about the cycling
I think the key this the the start of it
was can you live there without a car and
be economically active and I think the
loss of sort of roughly two-thirds of
the bus services means that you know no
longer can and it will be sustainable
but it isn't at the moment thank you
thank you
next up we have cancer mayor thank you
chair um fear of sounding like a broken
record up share concerns most of my
fellow councillors on my hand it's in a
sensible priced and it seems to be a
reasonable development but I am slightly
concerned about the ribbon development
is if all developments come to fruition
and then the two villages will become
very close together and also pick up on
the point made by the ward member that
things have been built in quickly
infrastructure the doctors surgeries our
schools have got to be given the chance
to keep up and at the moment they can't
provide the places and it's all very
well saying it's a county council
responsibility to bus the kids to where
ever they can try the school price but
surely sustainability has a time element
given in the medium-term is probably a
sustainable site but currently with all
the other development around I'm not
sure it is but then countering all of
that it is in the local plan or part of
the site well connected and so I
struggle I'm sitting on the fence on the
freight at the moment thank you thank
you for that
next up Katherine Miller Thank You chair
I too accept all the comments that they
made by my colleagues probably is one of
the only councilors it doesn't have a
car I can fully agree with the fact that
the bus service be totally inadequate if
you're trying to sort of get to work etc
or carry lots of shopping
however there are some benefits there's
gotta be benefits for the local
amenities and the use of the should
local shops etc the pub post-office it
does help the local housing need in the
district and it has got the potential to
generate stronger communities however I
fully accept what my colleague Keysha
Castro said about the farmland I fully
appreciate people objecting to this this
particular application but at the moment
I'm like the rest of us I think I'm
sitting on the fence on this one okay
so John you have one more comment sorry
Cal Sofia one more comment okay I'll set
about just to perhaps clarify that the
walking into it which recent transport
appeals committee decision was that that
is not a safe route for children
basically because of the width of the
pavements and lack of effective vitamins
then will that help sustainability okay
okay so we've all been around once and
we're going to need a propose been a
seconder for something I mean I'm I'm
Trevor I don't like to do that but
obviously in this format it's a bit more
difficult because we're not looking at
each other to see I can see if someone's
about to do it and does anyone want to
come forward
chair I'm happy to come forward with a
proposal okay
I do find this particularly difficult
and I really appreciate all the comments
have been made by the parish Clarke the
objector etc but I am finding very very
difficult to come up with this
application therefore I would have to
recommend that we go along with the
Planning Officers recommendation for
approval thank you okay around a couple
of points we've heard it mentions around
having an informative on the cycling
conditions from County burn around the
section two seven eight so could we just
have clarity on what that would look
like from officers if it was or wasn't
included could we also talk about a
couple other points that raisin just
clarity that the recommendations on page
44 and 45 are the recommendations to
approve both applications so Jack and
drum can you come in give us a high
return that yeah if I may come in
chairman on that on that particular
point um so I would possibly suggest to
counselors that if you're looking to go
forward with the approval recommendation
given the debate that has occurred you
may wish to consider adding two
conditions one being that the indicative
plan that had been the more upstate
indicative plan is the one that we
conditioned for future reserve matters
to be in general accordance with so we
in general accordance with the
indicative plan and the second condition
and I appreciate this hasn't been
basically mentioned but I given what's
been discussed I think it would be
applicable to apply would be that we put
a condition for the market mix of the
development to be agreed by the local
planning authority we have conditioned
this in past applications across the
district and given the local need for
housing I see no reason not to justify a
condition to have a Pacific condition on
a market mix of housing so we have
obviously I wanna see
agreement in respect of the affordable
housing mix but I you know
notwithstanding any indicative plan I
would actually have a condition separate
condition in respect of the agreement of
the market mix concurrent with the
reserved matters yeah you wish have an
informative in respect of cycling to say
that we see the priority in terms of
bringing forward design okay
given the spending decision-making on
this one would be with the County
Council would it be better that we
direct a letter to them rather than an
informative on the application to the
applicant Thank You chair I'm just very
anxious at that that doesn't get lost
and that you know I think for the scheme
to come forward we really do need that
cycling provision to be enhanced both
for pupils to the high schools and for
people to get to work and as councilman
saws mentioned cycling stations so I'm
not feeling lettuce I'm not sure the
lender is strong enough pointing out the
importance of the cycle route to give
access to obviously education facilities
and the town but also to have an
informative ended in the recommendation
just flagging up that this is we
consider this to be a key element of why
the commissioners been granted we can
use those yeah we can do both okay so so
at the moment we only have proposed by
councillor Miller and do we have any
other do we have a seconder first of all
before we go to more discussion can I
have a seconder
I'm having in here I'm happy okay thank
you okay
so do we have obviously so at the moment
we have a recommendation on page 44 and
45 with three additional points one
around the the plan on page 234
indicative plan that is the plan we'd
like to see come forward one around the
market mix to be agreed by missile
district council and three and a letter
and an informative around the psyche
conditions is there anything else anyone
would like to discuss at this point if I
may Chancellor Mansell I just like to
thank John pavement G for the suggested
conditions I'm very pleased to see that
we are pretty something in about the
market mix and the general layout so I
just like to compliment him thanking the
high-waist contribution for passenger
transport of a hundred and seventy
thousand pounds there was a during the
discussion we were informed that that
will disappear into a overall pot is
there possible to improve that condition
just to say that it should be spent to
the benefit of Brantford or you know
something slightly less prescriptive
perhaps but to ensure that it doesn't
disappear off into the the the pause as
we recording it is in is in relation to
the corridor of the the triple one free
so it's localized in terms of
improvements along that corridor if we
what are looking to essentially say that
it this has to end any money from this
development has to end within the
district itself that would localize
further but obviously that would
possibly restrict what the county wishes
to achieve in terms of road improvements
um if we're going to get into that then
that's a conversation we really need to
have with the county further the way
they want to go forward yeah it's not
highways improvement I was talking about
the passenger transport improvement
which it's not raised bus stops one
assumes that might be an Inc frequency
of bus services for instance but
preferably in this element of hips which
you know Brantford not in Lowestoft um I
would get I would have no problem we
would localizing it in the context of
this area you're right I wider Suffolk
is a different issue so I would I can we
can make sure the wording in the 106
agreement is in relation to this area
and restricts it to being wind wing
fenced in that context we can do that
that's fine thank you okay this point
what we'll do is there's now a proposal
that's been proposed by councilor mother
and seconded by Councillor had Ingham
regarding both recommend for gutting
with Trey both planning applications as
laid out in the recommendations on page
44 45 of the papers with the additional
of the three points raised around the
indicative plan on page two three for
the market mix and the informative
psyching condition with a note we're now
going to do a roll call on the vote so
can I ask the chief planning officer so
can I ask the who's going to do this do
I do it okay so when I call your name if
you could say for against or abstain
councillor Rachel either for
councils John field against counselor
Lavinia having him Paul counselor
Matthew Hicks counselor Sarah Mansell
for counselor John Matheson
councillor Matheson ya against
councillor Richard mayor poor and
councillor Dave Miller thank you I make
that six four and two against yes he is
this is Ian Fraley loss or I agree with
Claire that was six votes for two
against thank you very much for that and
thank you members yes yeah I was just
gonna mention obviously there was two
applications here do you need - yep only
that would you sort on the next
application walls is that all both
applications what's the advice pian I
think we ought to I think we ought to
vote on the other one chairman so we
voted so far just to be absolutely clear
[Music]
we're voting on different applications
that I need to be absolutely clear which
application refers to which part of the
site and I don't think I am I did say we
were voting on base at the same time so
sure I think I had overlooked that I
mean I think if this could be yes this
was a vote - yeah I apologize if that
was said chairman then it's a resolution
to refuse both has just been passed and
I'm content with that I'm sorry that's
what I meant to say sorry so can we be
absolutely clear I read out at the start
for the vote where this was both
applications were being voted on as laid
out on page 44 and 45 of the papers so
does that stand or do we need to do it
again right okay so just my fellow offer
that are speaking by fellow officers to
leave
planners the officers advice was that
both should be approved as that right
yes you was
yes of course it was so that and the
chairman said we are voting on both
applications and the proposal by
Councillor so sorry I need to remind it
was counselor had him move seconded and
cancel mala who proposed that was to
approve in accordance with the officers
recommendation
so either you Jim and you said that it
was for to both applications nobody
corrected you I'm content to advise you
that you'll offer custom resolution that
both planning applications be approved
in accordance with the officers advice
with the additional conditions that
weren't that weren't discussed and very
clearly and identified before the vote
was taken and if I may just clarify as
well both applications are precisely the
same in terms of proposal it's not no
difference between the two do you know
if all that was the case yes okay so on
that basis is everyone content is there
anyone not content all clear no okay
right so thank you very much everyone
inspections we closed the meeting at
11:43 thanks everyone for taking part
our next meeting isn't about a month
time will be on teams when we'll be able
to use the camera facility as well but
thank you very much and have a good
afternoon
thank you